From reincarnation to run-ins
with the Mafia and the FBI,
Steven Seagal has lived quite the
explosive life both on screen and off.
Before Steven Seagal became a major star on the
success of macho action flicks like Marked for
Death and Out for Justice, he had a bit of an
inspirational life story. Born in Michigan,
he moved with his parents to California,
where the frail and asthmatic young Steven
became obsessed with rock and roll and martial
arts. He learned aikido under the tutelage of
an older man of Japanese descent, then spent
some time in Japan before returning to the
U.S. to open a chain of successful dojos.
His story was so ready-made for Hollywood
that the movie industry had already
told versions of it. Several of his
biographical details bear a strong, albeit
coincidental, resemblance to The Karate Kid.
Even if Seagal's journey to becoming a warrior was
Hollywood fodder, it wasn't necessarily the image
he wanted to project. Often in interviews, he
would foreground his family's roots in Brooklyn,
presenting himself as a kid from the
block who made good. But that particular
bubble was burst in a 1990 People Magazine
profile, in which his mother Pam clarified
that his Brooklyn upbringing was limited to
a handful of family visits. She also noted,
"He was a puny kid back then."
The People profile punctured Seagal's
self-promoted image as a New York kid
and took aim at one of his tales about his
pre-Hollywood life. Seagal claimed that,
while living in Osaka in the 1970s
with his first wife Miyako Fujitani,
he performed training and consulting work for
the CIA. This bit of unverified history began
circulating in 1988, during the promotion
of his feature debut, Above the Law. The
film's plot follows rogue CIA operatives, and
Seagal claimed a certain amount of expertise
in the field and even suggested that the script
came from his own experiences as a company man.
Fujitani couldn't speak about her husband's
clandestine activities during their ten-year
marriage, although she did confirm to People that
there were long stretches of time when he was
unavailable. She also noted that while he could
have been guarding the Shah of Iran or Bishop
Desmond Tutu, as he claimed, it's just as likely
that he was a poor husband and absentee father.
In the early 90s, Seagal hired retired
intelligence officer Herbert Saunders
for security detail. Then in 2003, Saunders
confirmed to the New York Post that Seagal
pressed him to use his CIA abilities and
access to do everything from stealing
files from the Drug Enforcement Agency
to killing someone. As Saunders put it,
"I don't think he's able to
sort out fantasy from fact."
"There are an awful lot of people
who say that that's not true."
By the early 80s, Seagal was busy with
his aikido dojos in Osaka, Los Angeles,
and Taos, New Mexico. The North Hollywood location
quickly became the talk of the town, and in 1986,
the Los Angeles Times wrote a glowing story
about Seagal, generally taking his bold claims
about his mastery of aikido and Japanese culture
at face value. The paper reported that his time
in Osaka proved his mettle as a martial artist
and his disdain for impostor karate teachers.
Seagal's dojo attracted film industry
luminaries like James Mason and James Coburn,
but his most significant student was someone
less well-known to the public at large:
Hollywood super-agent and future Disney president
Michael Ovitz. In 1987, Ovitz arranged a martial
arts demonstration for a group of Warner Brothers
executives. While film studios had been sniffing
around Seagal for a few years, Ovitz was the one
who finally made it happen. He arranged for Seagal
to star in Above the Law, and helped him get
story and producer credits on the film as well.
Along with Ovitz, other Hollywood notables shaped
Seagal's career at this early stage — including
British actress and model Kelly LeBrock,
who had captivated audiences in the 80s
in such films as The Woman in Red and Weird
Science. She and Seagal met in Tokyo, where
she was shooting a fashion campaign, and their
relationship gave him some status that he might
not have enjoyed otherwise. The 1986 Los Angeles
Times profile of Seagal even included the claim,
"Kelly LeBrock [...] apparently was
his reward for years of self denial."
"Years of self-denial" is an odd way to
describe a decade of marriage to his first
wife that produced two children, but the
profile makes no mention of them. In fact,
Seagal had been married twice beforehand: in
1984, he married actress Adrienne La Russa,
despite still being legally married to Miyako
Fujitani. Within a year, La Russa annulled
their marriage, and by 1986, Fujitani
divorced him as well. As for LeBrock,
she and Seagal married in 1987, but their
union ended less than amicably in 1996.
Over the course of his career, Steven Seagal
has done quite a bit of fight choreography.
Most of the films he's choreographed
are his own — but in the early 80s,
he worked on the James Bond film Never Say
Never Again, training Sean Connery in martial
arts. Connery was already well-versed in karate:
while preparing for 1967's You Only Live Twice,
he was even awarded an honorary third-degree
black belt. But for his seventh outing as Bond, he
needed to learn a little aikido, so Seagal taught
him how to throw opponents and manipulate joints.
At first, the lessons seemed to be going well,
but then Connery got a little cocky… so an
irritated Seagal allegedly grabbed his arm
and broke the actor's wrist. While Connery
was undoubtedly in pain, he reportedly kept
training and didn't even realize the
extent of his injury until years later.
"15 years ago."
"And it's still broken?"
"Yeah, I just found out last year."
In his heyday, Steven Seagal was the biggest
martial arts star in Hollywood — but that
doesn't exactly mean that he could fight in
real life. He may be a seventh dan in aikido,
a martial art that relies on joint locks and the
redirection of momentum — but aikido is pretty
worthless when it comes to self-defense.
According to fight analyst Jack Slack,
"Aikido [...] famously only works if the
opponent is running straight at you."
Alas, this is something most smart fighters
never do — but nevertheless, Seagal claimed
that he could beat anyone, anywhere, anytime.
Furthermore, he made some controversial comments
about Bruce Lee, Chuck Norris, and full-contact
karate. This didn't sit well with Bob Wall,
an actor and high-ranking black belt with
plenty of tournament experience. Wall was
friends with Norris, had worked with Lee,
and didn't much care for Seagal's attitude.
That was when Wall assembled a group of kickboxing
and karate champions dubbed the "Dirty Dozen."
Some of them wanted to expose Seagal as a fake,
while others wanted to avenge some stuntmen he'd
allegedly injured. To get his attention,
the Dozen appeared in various magazines,
but there was ultimately never any physical
showdown. When Seagal finally met Wall,
the movie star reportedly
apologized for what he'd said.
Seagal has battled all sorts of bad guys on the
silver screen, from terrorists to the yakuza.
But he's also faced some villains in real life,
including the Mafia. In the 90s, the actor's
partnership with producer Julius R. Nasso resulted
in a string of hits. Alas, their relationship
soured in 2000, and things took a dark turn
when the Gambino crime family got involved.
One day, Seagal was reportedly
escorted to a Brooklyn restaurant,
where he met an alleged Gambino captain named
Anthony "Sonny" Ciccone. According to Seagal,
Ciccone ordered him to start working with
Nasso again and demanded that Seagal fork over
$150,000 for every film he made.
Evidently, Seagal was so shaken that
he gave the gangsters $700,000. As he left
the meeting, someone supposedly told him,
"If you would have said the wrong
thing, they would have killed you."
The scandal came to light in 2003, when
the government indicted alleged crime
boss Peter Gotti and 16 others for a host of
crimes. In addition to Seagal's testimony,
the government had recordings of several
individuals, including Ciccone and Nasso,
discussing how they would intimidate Seagal.
They even laughed about how they scared the
movie star. Nasso defended himself by saying
Seagal had backed out of several movie deals and
owed him $500,000. He was sentenced to one year
in federal prison, though he still sued Seagal
for $60 million. After Nasso got out of jail, he
settled with the actor for an undisclosed amount.
"I still know a thing or two."
While never a critical darling, Seagal
used to pull in some impressive box
office numbers. These days, though,
Seagal's films tend to go straight to
video on demand — and he blames his
decline on, of all things, the FBI.
In 2002, Los Angeles Times reporter Anita
Busch was investigating Seagal and Julius
Nasso. One morning, she found a dead fish,
a rose, and a sign that read "Stop!" on her
windshield. She informed the FBI, who
began investigating Seagal. At first,
the feds thought that he'd hired a detective
named Anthony Pellicano to intimidate Busch.
They also suspected Seagal of hiring a thug to
scare Vanity Fair writer Ned Zeman with a gun.
But after digging deeper, the FBI concluded that
there was no evidence against Seagal. Instead,
they focused on Pellicano, the private
eye who illegally spied on celebrities.
The FBI never charged Seagal, but they didn't
exactly exonerate him either — and he believes
all the notoriety from the Pellicano
case significantly harmed his career.
It may not surprise you to learn that Steven
Seagal is fascinated with law enforcement. He
even served as a cop in Jefferson Parish,
Louisiana for about 20 years. In 2009, the
actor took things to the next level by starring
in a reality show called Steven Seagal: Lawman.
In the third season of the show, Seagal
moved to Arizona and teamed up with
controversial Sheriff Joe Arpaio of Maricopa
County. Arpaio is an infamous media hound,
so when Seagal showed up with a camera in tow, the
sheriff decided to put on a very memorable show.
In 2011, Arpaio orchestrated
a raid against Jesus Llovera,
a local man suspected of cockfighting. When
the cops arrived, they had more than just a
warrant. There were up to 40 SWAT officers,
a bomb squad, K-9 units, armored vehicles,
and even Seagal riding on top of a tank. During
the raid, parts of the suspect's house were
damaged, as Seagal's tank tore down the gates
to Llovera's property. After arresting Llovera,
Seagal and Maricopa officials discovered that
Llovera owned over 100 roosters, which they
decided to euthanize. Llovera even claimed that
the police also killed his 11-month-old puppy.
"Animal cruelty is one of my, uh, pet peeves."
Llovera started to file a lawsuit against
the Maricopa County Sheriff's Office and
demanded an apology letter from Seagal —
but after pleading guilty to cockfighting,
the lawsuit was dropped. As for the
raid, it ultimately never aired on TV.
As someone who's so famous for breaking bones,
Steven Seagal is surprisingly gentle towards
animals. He's both a vegetarian and something
of an activist. In 1999, Seagal worked to force
South Africa to stop exporting baby elephants
to Japan and received a PETA Humanitarian Award
for his efforts. Four years later, he wrote to
the government of Thailand to get them to stop
torturing baby elephants. He's also attempted
to shame India into treating cows better.
But Seagal's favorite animals of all are of the
soothsaying variety. During an interview with
PETA, he claimed that while he was learning
aikido in Japan, a white dog greeted him.
After a few days, the canine started barking,
apparently telepathically warning him that
his dojo was on fire. Seagal put the fire out,
and the dog disappeared, never to bark again.
"Cause I'm an animal lover,
you know? 'Animal lover'?"
"Yeah."
Seagal's hands aren't just for busting up bodies.
They're also for making sweet, sweet music,
as he is a long-time musician who loves himself
some blues. Seagal has been playing guitar since
age 12, and he's the frontman of the aptly
named Steven Seagal Blues Band. In 2005,
he released his first album, entitled Songs From
the Crystal Cave. Overall, it's a straightforward
blues record, not nearly as grimy and soulful as
the likes of B.B. King or Buddy Guy. SputnikMusic
wasn't exactly impressed, calling it "the Plan
9 From Outer Space of records" in their review.
We're inclined to agree with that take,
as the track entitled "Music" barely
qualifies as music. Meanwhile, "Girl, It's
Alright" sounds like the first song that
Jack Johnson threw in the trash. And then
there's "Jealousy," a hungry ghost song
that could maybe serve as inspiration
for a high school yearbook quote tune.
Energy drinks boomed in the mid-2000s.
With the success of Red Bull and Monster,
dozens of competitors flooded the market, and
they were often endorsed by celebrities. A certain
action star got in on the game in 2005 with the
release of Steven Seagal's Lightning Bolt, a
ginseng and goji berry-powered drink available in
two flavors: Cherry Charge and Asian Experience.
Seagal released a baffling two-minute commercial
featuring himself and swimsuit models hanging
out by a pool. The premise was that he was so
enamored by his own beverage that he wanted to
swim in it. It's hard to decide which element of
the ad is more offensive: ingredients with names
like "Tibetan Goji" and "Asian Cordyceps," the
models being unable to fake any chemistry with
Seagal, or the nondescript blues guitar score.
Reviews of the drink were less than appetizing,
though cans are still available through eBay if
you really want to try them after all these years.
"Lightning Bolt: try it today. It's electric."
Russian President Vladimir Putin has a reputation
as a dictator and human rights violator,
but Steven Seagal doesn't exactly see him
that way. He's even been quoted as saying —
"I know him well enough to know that he
is one of the greatest world leaders,
if not the greatest world leader, alive today."
The two met in 2003 at the Moscow Film Festival
and quickly hit it off — probably thanks to
their shared love of martial arts, as Putin
is an eighth-degree black belt in judo. Soon,
they were dining together, visiting dojos,
and promoting old Soviet exercise programs.
They even visited the Russian judo team
during preparation for the 2012 Olympics.
In 2015, Putin asked President Barack Obama
to make Seagal an honorary consul of Russia,
but Obama vetoed that idea pretty quickly.
Despite that, Seagal visits Russia frequently.
He has given aikido demonstrations, visited
the factory that produces Kalashnikov rifles,
attended a parade on the 70th anniversary
of the Nazi surrender to the Soviet Union,
and played a concert for pro-Russian
separatists in the Crimean Peninsula.
In November 2016, Seagal officially received
a Russian passport and became a citizen of
the country. What's more, Putin personally
signed the passport and expressed his hope
that the stunt would promote a normalization of
relations between the United States and Russia.
But it appears that this new Russian citizen
is already grinding other countries' gears,
as it was announced in May 2017 that Seagal
would be banned from entering Ukraine for
five years. According to the Ukraine Security
Service, the ban was implemented "on the basis
of Ukrainian national security," likely
due to Seagal's admiration for Russia's
aggressive tactics in the region. There was no
word on whether his movies were banned as well,
though we have to imagine he's not winning
any popularity contests over there.
In 2023, Steven Seagal received
the Russian Order of Friendship,
a civilian honor available to both citizens
and non-citizens of Russia. The year prior,
a holding company co-owned by Seagal earned
a parcel of land outside Moscow to build a
martial arts center. The area had reportedly been
previously set aside for a children's hospital.
Seagal's cozy relationship with Putin
aside, the Order of Friendship is no
empty gesture. Established by former
president Boris Yeltsin in 1994,
the recognition has been bestowed on dozens
of political and cultural figures. Past
honorees have included chess master Anatoly
Karpov, orchestra conductor Riccardo Muti,
and Queen Elizabeth II'scousin, Prince Michael
of Kent, who gave his medal back in protest of
the war in Ukraine. Canadian politician Adrienne
Clarkson and Norwegian politician Rune Rafaelsen
have also both returned their Orders of
Friendship since the start of the war.
"Russia and America should be great
allies, and that's the way it should be."
Steven Seagal is a man of contrasts. He's
a high-profile Hollywood Buddhist and
supporter of environmental causes,
while simultaneously a champion
of strongman regimes and corresponding
paranoid reactionary politics. In 2018,
Seagal took his first dip into literary
waters with the release of his debut book,
The Way of the Shadow Wolves: The Deep State
and the Hijacking of America. The book was
co-written by Arizona politician Tom Morrissey
and includes a foreword by Sheriff Joe Arpaio.
The story is a hodgepodge of Trump-era
conspiracies surrounding the Deep State,
the supposed group of unelected
bureaucrats plotting against the
American people from deep within the federal
government. Their master plan is to smuggle
Middle Eastern terrorists through the
Mexican border, but standing in their
way is Tribal officer and shameless Seagal
avatar John Nan Tan Gode. He's a Mohawk,
or an Apache, depending on the chapter.
He's also a member of the Shadow Wolves,
a real-life Indigenous patrol unit that works
under the Department of Homeland Security.
Seagal and Morrisey depict the Shadow Wolves as
so morally pure and in harmony with the land that
they have nearly supernatural abilities. The
mysticism would be offensive if the writing
wasn't so laughably bad. Curious minds can
still find the novel available for purchase,
but you might be better off reading one of
the book's many bewildered reviews instead.
Steven Seagal is willing to lend his name and
image to some dicey projects, and there's perhaps
no riskier example in his personal history than
the cryptocurrency bonanza of the late 2010s and
early 2020s. In the first quarter of 2018, Seagal
went to bat for a project called Bitcoiin2gen,
also known as B2G. He promoted the coin
on his social media pages and allowed his
likeness to appear on official branding,
without disclosing that he'd been promised
$250,000 in cash and another $750,000 in B2G
tokens for his endorsement. If you're an expert
in white-collar crime, you'll know that this
is a violation of federal anti-touting law.
In 2020, the Securities and Exchange Commission
came down hard on Seagal for his violations,
issuing fines of $157,000 in disgorgement and
another $157,000 in penalties. Seagal paid
$75,000 towards that total and then fled
to Russia, hoping that his status as a
Russian citizen and close friendship with Putin
would keep the rest of his money safe. However,
in 2021 a federal judge ruled that
the SEC was still owed the full
penalty and could collect it through
Seagal's business manager. As for B2G,
founder John DeMarr faced fraud charges that led
to a five-year prison sentence in January 2023.
According to multiple actors that he's
worked with, Steven Seagal isn't exactly
the most pleasant co-star. For example,
while filming 1996's Executive Decision,
he allegedly shoved John Leguizamo against a wall.
"He caught me off guard and knocked all
the air out of me. I was like, 'Why? Why?'"
Seagal also made life hard for the
Saturday Night Live cast when he hosted
an episode in April 1991. As Tim Meadows
revealed in the book Live from New York,
"He didn't realize that you
can't tell somebody they're
stupid on Wednesday and expect them to
continue writing for you on Saturday."
And according to fellow cast member Julia Sweeney,
Seagal wanted to perform a sketch
where he played a therapist who
wants to sleep with a rape survivor. He was
reportedly banned from ever hosting again.
"Steven Seagal was so horrible on such a scale,
it was such a huge scale of terribleness."
In 1996's The Glimmer Man, Stephen Tobolowsky
played a serial killer who was supposed to be
defeated by Seagal's character, but Seagal had
decided that it was bad karma to keep killing
people on-screen. Tobolowsky explained that his
character was trapped in his own private hell,
and by killing the villain, Seagal would
be allowing the bad guy to reincarnate
as a more peaceful being. Seagal agreed, and
the scene went on as scripted. Unfortunately,
Seagal later ad-libbed the line "Thank God,
I didn't kill that guy." Tobolowsky then had
to record a few lines to make it seem
like his obviously dead character had
somehow survived. However, those lines
ultimately didn't make the final cut.
In 1997, Penor Rinpoche, the Supreme Head
of the Nyingma School of Tibetan Buddhism,
announced that Steven Seagal was a reincarnated
Buddhist master. Rinpoche asserted that in the
17th century, Seagal was Terton Chungdrag
Dorje, a renowned translator who opened a
monastery and found several powerful relics.
Thanks to this supposed spiritual history,
Seagal was declared a lama, which
is a venerated teacher in Tibetan
Buddhism. During his inauguration, Seagal
pledged to help ease suffering across the
globe — and since then, he's given seminars
on compassion at New Age retreat centers.
However, several people are skeptical of Seagal's
spiritual status. Since he's been accused of
sexual harassment, many have questioned
his moral character. Others allege that
before he was declared a Buddhist master, Seagal
donated quite a bit of cash to Rinpoche's school,
which might explain his conveniently
glorious past life. It's all especially
abnormal considering that these reincarnated
teachers are generally discovered as children.
In 2018, Emmy-winning actress Julianna
Margulies was a guest on The Katie Couric
Podcast. The ladies discussed the #MeToo
movement, and Margulies recalled a hotel
room meeting she'd had with Steven Seagal
in the early 90s. When a casting director
told her that Seagal wanted to go
over a scene with her in his room,
she went, under the assumption that the casting
director would also attend. As she recalled,
"I walked in and I sat down and I
jumped right back up because there
was something very uncomfortable and hard in
the couch. He laughed and said, 'Oh, sorry,
that must have been my gun. He lifted
up the cushion and he took out his gun."
When Margulies grew nervous, Seagal explained,
"Oh, it's just for all the crazies that
are out there. I have to protect myself."
Seagal also claimed to be a "healer" and
asked to read Margulies's palms. He told
her that she had weak kidneys — and shortly
thereafter, she managed to get out of the
room. But then she realized that she hadn't
received the cab fare she'd been promised,
so she went back and asked for it. She got the
cash, as well as the part in Out for Justice,
but she also demanded never to
be alone with Seagal on set.
"The tough New Yorker in me just inwardly was
laughing because it was so awful and hilarious."
Seagal has faced accusations of sexual
misconduct throughout his career,
ranging from harassment to assault to even sex
trafficking. In one instance, images surfaced
of the actor groping his Under Siege 2 co-star
Katherine Heigl, who was only 16 at the time.
"He said, 'You know, Katie, I've got
girlfriends your age.' And I said,
'Isn't that illegal?' And he said, 'They
don't seem to mind.' And I said, 'Mom!'"
In 1991, actress Raenne Malone, who was Seagal's
assistant on Out for Justice, and three other
women accused him of sexual harassment. Warner
Brothers ultimately reportedly paid them $50,000
each. Other incidents have also made headlines
without resulting in any legal consequences.
Then in 2017, the #MeToo movement cast
a light on serial predators in the
entertainment industry. Suddenly, decades
of allegations against Seagal could no
longer be overlooked. Portia de Rossi came
forward with casting couch horror stories,
while model Faviola Dadis and actor Regina Simons
accused Seagal of rape. The Los Angeles County
District Attorney's office investigated Dadis
and Simons' claims in 2018, though no charges
resulted. In total, more than a dozen women
have reportedly accused Seagal of sex crimes.